Grahame's vision guides FHIR development.
So, before we delve into the standard,
it's important to understand his philosophy.
The FHIR Data Model consists of resources as Grahame propose for RFH.
Unlike HL7's CCDA and RIM,
resource contents are intentionally limited.
FHIR's 80% rule is the operative guideline and it informally states that
each resource should contain
only those data elements needed for 80% or more of its anticipated use cases.
Of course, as Grahame has posted,
there are other considerations such as safety and consistency.
All standards efforts must grapple with tension between comprehensiveness and usability.
In essence, this approach means that in FHIR,
usability is a top priority.
Grahame's second principle is around how to verify the standard.
Historically, a vote of standards developers approves the standard they created.
Input from software developers who have worked with proposed FHIR resources,
APIs, and other elements of the standard guides further development of FHIR.
Again, usability is a priority.
The third principle is the use of
Cross Industry Web Technologies to search for resources and to create,
read, update, and delete them, CRUD, C-R-U-D.
This makes the standard more approachable and hence,
more attractive to modern developers,
and provides the basis for FHIR base mobile and web apps that can be EHR-agnostic.